yeah hello welcome to this broadcast
sometimes the messages of the software
irritating yeah hope everyone is alright
hope you had a good term Halloween if
you do anything with that with that day
no extra play you're not late we just
stayed started on second seconds ago so
you're welcome everybody in the chat
everybody around let's see i see some
regulars there yeah welcome to other
regular viewers and the ones in the chat
I'm going to kick off with a couple of
blitz games as I usually do let's get
going some five-minute action there are
a couple of pretty strong five-minute
players around okay Carol I am too but
it's not an IM so let's get going
someone says it's about a start it
started already so hope the broadcast is
working working fine so we have a semi
Slav let me check yeah it should should
be working all right so somewhere Slav
entire Marin with quincy tomb and the
line that i don't know that well yeah i
know that this is supposed to be good
for white snowy form black has some
problems there with space in the center
go to meat grinder Joe's in yo Hobgoblin
yeah all the regulars
yeah white has more space it's not easy
not easy to play for black yeah thanks
for the message that I'm live yeah it
went f5 and wonder is it a good idea to
play Bishop g5 now well I think I'll go
back here
yeah me there was some lack in the int
which it happens yeah I CC and now is
usually on streaming and now unknown via
via YouTube direct the YouTube but I'm
not doing that because o carro this is a
tactic and I'm not doing that because in
Germany we don't have youtube streaming
there is a somehow this is not possible
in Germany due to some copyright laws
and yeah therefore i'm still on twitch
yeah I rookie 6 nice nice little tactic
going on what now I can even go look
chicks age 6 that's a bit of a fancy
move let's do that come on let's have
some fun iam yeah I'm still threatening
Bishop c4 so 95 voice that is that wrong
I have to be alert ian not to run into
something really stupid yeah I guess
Bishop c4 is good though he cannot go
Bishop b6 has to go with 95 and here
well the rook now is hanging so I should
probably move it 95 the screen 37 and
this doesn't look good no I'm just going
back with the rook
yeah we have we don't have youtube
streaming in Germany it somehow is is
forbidden okay i'm going to play now
that's not great let's just keep
everything on yeah i think they will
probably find some kind of solution for
the youtube streaming issue we with day
I mean YouTube it's not a matter of ICC
or me or somebody else because I think
certainly YouTube is some is interested
in getting the streaming going in
Germany I think it's forbidden jutsu
yeah German copyright laws they I think
they fear that people would stream music
I'm going to play this in a somewhat
somewhat term strategic fashion trading
of this trading off the dark squared
bishop and coming with the knight to e5
this is certainly a good a good option
yeah here I thought that drug h3g three
is good I hope them I'm right with that
rock g3 and Bishop b5 next or maybe 95
depending on what he does look g5 stead
any good don't know i think Bishop b5 is
fine attacking g7 aha so he wants to
take on g3 okay well that's not not a
big issue f4 maybe is coming i'm going
to look at the dark squares yellow to
Paris and hello to stock on this sounds
like the the eurovision song contest
right hello to the jury in Stockholm the
fear or something like that yeah i would
like to play kawana
it would be cool I played him on video
once and lost a pretty drastic game
played very well I've beaten him once on
the iucn blitz but it was a very lucky
win we're somehow yeah somehow he
stumbled into some kind of made or so it
was it was very weird was a very yeah
somewhat illogical win on my end so um
let's have a look down he's trying for
this count of play I think I'm just
playing it to keep koalas username in
that game was adaptation but i think i
think i have the name in yeah my very
first english video was against nakamura
which was really a coincidence nobody
probably believes that but i started out
with a couple of german language videos
and then at one point I thought okay
let's do let's do let's do English and
then the very first game that was coming
up was really Nakamura that was really
great couldn't really couldn't believe
it but it really happened it's hard to
say what's Germans Germany is most
popular beers and because some the the
various regions of Germany have
different beers probably some kind of
some kind of ice beer bioshock's whites
are probably can tell you about it not
quite sure which brand Oettinger made
might be there's also adding or and
franciscana and and all kinds of things
but in my area of Germany for example we
we have different types of beers we
usually have typical pills in a BM or in
the particular region where I live we
also have I'd be of 08 beer which is a
darker darker version
and so um he went night a for Queen g3
or I can also go Bishop to c7 that's
probably not bad let's do that there's a
random at in the middle of the stream
that's weird a case I'm taking here for
the paw yep and black resigns yeah that
was so nice agustina edel stuff I never
heard of that one interesting I was
still a little sheet I've never heard of
that Oh shaving and there's no clear
answer to that in them he asked about
the [ __ ] in variation in the Rue
Lopez went to trade on d4 and so on hmm
thats it's difficult to say really it
really depends on the precise line in
many cases I think nowadays that it's
clear that black probably should open
the sea fowl we see takes d4 which I
normally don't do my way of playing the
children is pretty pretty am old
fashioned and somewhat passive I've
never been to the oktoberfest which is
probably a yeah weird to some people but
I've never been the reason is that i'm
not really a huge fan of huge crowds I
don't like to be in a huge crowd of
people and this includes a places like
Oktoberfest yeah i'm looking forward to
bo Logan's book it is in the mail and
should and should arrive tomorrow at my
place i will also definitely do a review
yeah the white is kind of contrast II
but it's a little bit little bit tricky
yeah the marshal and the brea are the
choices of Boone Logan in the book and
very logical choices yeah it's not
available on UK amazon no feeling within
a puzzle yeah there was a request to to
greet someone yeah I'm happy to do that
yeah Christophe in bars i yam okay so um
let's talk a little bit about this game
I'm happy with this position I've got a
good space and i can trade this good
Bishop off night to be four hmm
interesting not quite sure what the
point is I can even go back let's go
back and keep the pieces on play c5
later the issue here is that black has
more space Black has more space in this
position I like it very much oh it's a
fan of space so what is blacks play here
i'm not quite sure about it yeah this
one i was thinking that c5 should be a
good move here i'm kicking this back and
95 quincy seven wins apiece so what now
I think I'm just going back here and now
we see 5 I have excellent support of the
center
yeah f5 that's a question what is the
most aggressive opening that I play in
tournaments hmm I don't know I have
played some aggressive openings over the
years um I'm not playing that many at
the moment that you would call very
aggressive I have played them the
blumenfeld gambit a couple of times in
tournament chess eat some years ago I've
also played them also play the landing
of Dutch a bit but yeah and I played the
Kings in yet a lot of course it's the
issue is that the the events or the
stuff that I normally play them is
leaked chess and in leaked chess playing
super sharp openings is often not the
wisest idea yeah I usually play on
pretty high BOTS so I have good
opponents and oftentimes playing in a
solid way does make lots of sense so I'm
usually play um somewhat somewhat you
have solid openings let's say nothing
that would be perceived as very very
aggressive by by normal standards so
let's see I think I go Quincy 6 cm and
in many cases with those league games
may also play opponents that I could not
prepare against this is also important
to keep in mind so it's difficult to
play super sharp opening so unprepared
so here g4 it takes I take and I'm
threatening made on g2 that you can only
parry with it this and now 96-95 happens
that should win material you cannot move
the rock is the problem as is always
made
so f4 or not I can be played takes Luke
cheeks now that cesium come on let's
take and my league start thanks for the
question we we have not yet plate that's
kind of funny the first round in the
second German Bundesliga we have not yet
played the first round we won because
the opposing team did not compete that's
a bit of a complicated story but they
did not compete and the second round was
delayed due to the rapid and blitz about
championships so we have not yet started
my league will start in about two weeks
will play against the second team of Zhu
Ling and very strong team and I probably
play some 2550 rated Grandmaster yellow
to go fix mix hello to London got a very
very good multi-national crowd here so
I'm taking c4 and hope that this is as
strong as I think it is Oh as a as a
rupiah mr. tellegio ok yeah by Usher
schweitzer is it expensive to play in
the Germans second league no it's not
the Germans second leak is is also
divided into regions so we have a we
have a North second ignores house west
and east so that means that we are
playing in the West group which means
that quite often we have teams that are
not so far away f three words the names
were as a main weapon is good is a very
sharp line and
can probably catch many not well
prepared players to get a good advantage
f3 is a good line but it is very sharp
mm I don't have so many that's a
question about old games as a junior no
I don't really have have games there ok
so let's play em cool rehear flynner
asks he is considered to add the modern
benoni to my repertoire this afternoon
how much time should I set aside and
yeah start with looking at a couple of
tower games yeah thar was a great model
benoni player and then after you got
into the right frame of mind and just
look at games by a ruger gaseum of the
greatest modern benoni player of of the
recent times unfortunately deceased so
there was a question however that I did
not there was some question that I
wanted to ask but it's now um screw it
out of the chair i cannot scroll up i
can actually let me check an easy and
easy to play set up against the Kings
Indian hmm that's not so easy um if you
really feel uncomfortable with most
lines and what you can try is you can
play something with d4c 493 Knight f3
Bishop g5 sometimes called dismissal of
variation that is not a bad line at all
the greatest specialist nowadays of this
is some is some nah volusia hakobyan
um and cobian usually gets very good
positions with deadlines it's something
that I've also played from time to time
when I wanted something simple against
the Kings Indian and yeah I didn't want
any yeah any big preparation a possible
of course yeah you can play the
fianchetto or the pietà or the exchange
variation and what this guy is playing
is really weird for a player of that
level you just plays strange strange
move and he is slow of course you can
play the London system against the Kings
Indian defense but it is not very
exciting if you want a little bit more
bite but still a solid play that line
that i mentioned that smooth slope
system is kind of interesting so i'm
going to take and see what happens i
would like to go night a six year but
let's go over yeah i think a cobian did
a lecture on that yeah in the on the San
Luis chess club website he's the
greatest specialist of that of that line
nowadays yeah m qu user is in my book is
a cheetah yes I have reported him but
he's not yet band I only yesterday
reported him so it might might take a
while
yeah for no you're right against the
modern been only those other systems
also the e4 f4e 4f for business so how
am i playing here maybe go back yeah the
timing of attack with F for something
that you need some prep against and the
Benoni it's still quite quite important
on the especially on the non super GM
level yeah I tried to get the night over
to d4 which I managed that's good news
she coming with f4 maybe maybe it's got
f4 hmm the balloon defense is there is
it any good yeah I guess it is so it's
the main defense against one year for
nowadays so it should be pretty good and
it's played by all the top players
yet the Berlin defense 39 f 6 against
the rule no pass it makes an awful lot
of sense if you want if you of you think
of it it makes a lot of sense because um
it attacks the e4 pawn directly and
white has a hard time to keep it and if
you get the four ponies black it's a
huge accomplishment simply so probably
not f6 is a good reply against the way
and it's a Sicilian the best way to play
for win against efore and it's certainly
the best way if you want to look at
mostly mainstream openings I think
another good try to play for win and if
you really um yeah must and balance is
something like the the modern defends or
the pills defense I'm not sure that i'm
pronouncing this right probably not and
that's also something that that many top
players have in their repertoire as
backup lines okay I'm trying to trade
stuff yeah maybe maybe I can flag him
luke t 1 i'm not so sure ever played
that i played this so well to be honest
i have my doubts night is six
ah doesn't doesn't seem so great I
shouldn't have done that to be honest i
forgot that after night f7 he doesn't
have that that i don't have that many
moves here I'm running out of moves a
little bit kingi form I can mop bring
the King up hmm yeah King King g4 as
possible i really don't i don't have
many moves
okay didn't expect that I did didn't
expect that I could get 98 in in the
first place okay I'm overlooking
something or is he just going Kings you
for it's possible Kings you [ __ ] at
five yeah he takes lots of time on g6
maybe this one I don't know he has
ripped his six and A six but he's not
speeding up its not speeding up at all
so probably I will win against this
engine on time so kicking takes takes
takes this is probably the toughest and
I'm on the building defense there are
two good books there's a more um yeah
let's say theoretical theory heavy book
by I think Ovechkin and some other guy
two Russians yeah he just forfeited on
time yeah I don't know this guy should
be bent yeah it's a typical engine
abuser and yeah I just somehow hole to
help the position and the knee run out
of time I don't know and so and this is
a veg chicken book and there is also
great book by John Cox on the modern
benoni there's the GM repertoire by
Maayan Petrov I've got khurana guys I've
got karana that's cool let's play mr.
fabiano caruana adaptation so this is
not an engine just a very good chess
player that's much better okay so um
I'm going from the NIMS oh and play the
play my same as you see what he does
it's super risky of course against such
a good player but we will see the main
line I guess no egos with t6 that's an
interesting line let's see what he comes
up with I always thought that this is a
good line for white but we'll see we'll
see um 92 I guess so is this an f3
position already f3 g4 age 6 it's a
debatable move yeah he's going for that
I think that h4 is good for Wyatt in
this position well ch44 I liked the big
expansion there uh-huh okay I don't want
to seeby five so early on and I like my
position a lot actually be five is tough
to play you can only you can start to
sacrifice stuff with be five anyway I'm
pushing my pawns iam this is a great
position for white and to be honest it's
just just quite nice so okay let's see
gets interesting so this will be an
interesting game I mean I'm threatening
to take age six and he does not want to
take g5 this is clear yeah I think I'm
clearly better here to be honest yeah
yeah yes to do something like that
something something desperate okay I'm
taking with the pawn I guess I can also
take age six and that's not bad either
yeah I'll take this first and then take
h6 I guess gee 69 f 5 is strong g6 this
is strong for white I can just take him
now h5 is good but taking us all so good
that will win material Eric rook takes
Bishop d3 wins material Luke g7 rugby 7s
looking strong but he has he has a rook
f7 okay it's good for Wyatt but is it
the best way to play I also think f4
might be an interesting try but he of
course he has rook g ade I have Bishop
g5 as well maybe this move I'm not sure
about it that's the position is winning
objectively for white but it's still
tricky and it's Kara wanna do I go F for
this is also interesting for loop c6
i recreate maybe I'm playing this a
little bit loose IAM that's a problem I
mean used to better play anyway and is
like 10 times better tactics that I am
so I'm trying for Luke a 7
I've got rook takes h7 may be coming
like on cream b6 I've Luke takes h7
where is he going to see aid or
something Quincy aid I can still take
them if I check here what is happening I
can chicken interpose on c7 hmm
what a wacky position Bishop aged five
maybe I cannot calculate any of that
impossible rook g7 yearbook f7
seagoing Queenie six maybe for Queenie
to a stop oh my god by the position
queen is six I don't know I'm an
exchange up for porn queen e six min I
don't really see a great move against
that I can take here Queen a seven oh
wait that's actually interesting takes
check let's do that 97 rookie one and
using a pen a pretty awful pin eyes got
queen III son of a gun
there should be seven creamy three okay
I have to check anyway and now d 1 is
checked so i have to go here Quincy
three there they are okay I maybe I can
get a draw here out of that
and I just died before check I cannot
calculate this 93 yards so maybe I'm
checkmated don't know okay i blundered
my queen oh that's a shame it's a shame
ok now I'm just not good enough at
calculating and calculating variation
that was a win for white at some point
pretty sure about it but yeah it's not
exactly easy to beat hmm I don't know
this is this is a great position for
white somewhere around here but
obviously difficult to play yeah ok I
can look at I can look at at the
computer there but i don't know like to
know i mean it's pretty clear that
somewhere around here white should be
winning yeah engine is on plus 2 with
something like fe fire but the position
is just the total mess this is winning
for white for example yeah that even
looks that looks kind of doable not nice
super messy yeah a couple of couple of
things a couple of things but yeah what
can you do it's a not exactly the
easiest guy to beat ok so let's get into
the next game open yagami it's also very
high rated player and let's go e6
there's a question can you talk a bit
about income in the
2nd bundesliga hmm what what shall I
tell you them in the first and second
league yeah of course they they usually
pay the players yep cannot expect much
but it's not something to discuss on the
chest stream you definitely cannot I
mean if you play em just in the
Bundesliga or something you cannot
expect any great income look T 1 really
huh I dared it be if I by not be five
now what is your big point there should
be three or something hmm never saw that
idea Bishop e7 a b5 takes tags mmm yeah
let's go Bishop e7
kind of surprised as I've never seen
that line ever and usually at least i
have seen lines that are that are played
ok i'm taking here and he gets c4 but i
doubt that this is some brilliant for
white see 594 ok gotten rid of my
catalan bishop on c8 usually the problem
peace how great to have gotten kewanee
on the stream that's that's nice hi
errant robo or air and robo i know you
play all the sim you let me you play the
fat all the time so and aaron traveler
asks a book about the solid line of the
Queens gambit or the sloth and there's a
good book about the Queens gambit
declined by John Cox again um and it's
about the last girl variation enter and
now the the tar take over 96 kind of
shaky so let's end the sloth sloth
depends upon what what lines this of
course the GM um yeah it's cox co x not
what you were thinking about um so what
was the sloth yeah this is book by boris
a brook of course a classical sloth
which is the current
standard let's say oh 96
and I have to take knight c6 rookie 7i
guess
yeah the top GMS don't really care much
about YouTube channels they have other
things to worry about like what to do
against them put in defense and stuff
like that okay um whoopsie eight or
something and then nobody six comes this
is it taking a 6 mm okay it looks
awfully passive but maybe I have 2 t-3
ha it's not exactly convenient here this
position may be back or so i don't know
i don't like it trying to trade stuff
runs into Bishop f4 but then Bishop t6
maybe it's still kind of okay but not
not great-looking this position yep
yeah txtx you threatening look b8
unfortunately
um wait a membership ticks ticks and so
am Bishop f4 look p8 queen bee at night
p 8 Bishop and a sort of work hmm that's
a bloody shame now I can go age six it's
not that terrible
his position is not perfectly
coordinated okay
cannot take with the night and I don't
think you can take with the bishop
either
but I don't really see how to exploit
this weird setup that he has hmm it
looks strange hmm should be too i guess
but i don't see anything right after
Bishop t 295 he moves the Queen yeah
let's sit sir Blitzen
cannot move my queen at all weird very
very weird
Wow yea my queen is still made it that
is exactly this is exactly the problem
yep now it's made it yeah that looked
really weird that that whole setup that
he had but maybe it was just wrong where
did he miss Ruby 8 I don't know why did
he miss Ruby 8 I mean I know I think he
played it played well at least I
couldn't couldn't figure out something
great okay so let's see the next game
coming up yeah time warning the Blitzen
software rook a6 rupee ADA take on the
air on b8 his queen is also hanging here
Ruby 8i take on be eight yeah koala
again
um magnus carlsen is probably not
playing on the ICC pub in a public
account but probably am here they will
players with some anonymous accounts I
mean he played ton ton of online be tons
of online blitz as a kid I also played
him when he was like 10 or 11 years old
but I don't have the games oh the
yardbird a regular regular opponent and
no I don't do challenges from the chat
normally this is for the been to blitz
sessions my show is a bit different i
usually just play five minute poor so we
get a Catalan here or maybe the yard but
will allow um them how it is called the
terrace a six that's an eccentric north
hmm
yeah he just he played the taraji with a
six that shouldn't be good let's see
what happens it's a question my opinion
about the English you mean the English
people or the English opening the
English breakfast I don't mind any of it
I don't want that the wrong way to sobe
the way to tart I mean I have no
particular objection against anything
English I mean some of the food is kind
of atrocious but it's a yeah what can
you do so takes and see now this must be
a good position d 5 he wants to set up a
pin but I have 95 and then you would
probably just cancel
85 fruity 892 5555 rock t5 night before
well I don't know that looks shaky if i
enter any other at the line t-55 OOP t8
yeah i mean i can go nighty fire but he
will just castle I didn't that didn't
seem didn't seem enough to me I should
have canceled that such was was stronger
I think okay Queen a 4 let's go now then
quit no Quinn f was okay hmm Queen B 5 I
thought but then Bishop c6 he has to
move the king mmm now rook e1 shouldn't
be bad Queen B 5 Queen a3 is good I
don't want to go into self pen that's
kind of important no Queen before I
would take the English breakfast I don't
mind the English black breakfast I
rather like that I mean it's not
particularly healthy but i still cannot
resist quite often so what about this
Bishop a six
before looks kind of wrong
we should be a group before is probably
wrong so I'm going back not quite sure
where I don't know cygwin would be too
maybe is
yeah he gets his typical activity that
he always seems to get shoot I didn't I
really should have reviewed this this
opening and didn't didn't do so now see
pawn gets very very dangerous now I
don't have any chicks c 3 i've got check
on edge for that that could be something
let's just go here maybe also Queen to
the seminar room to disown ah oh my god
hahaha it's been a long day okay ah yeah
that's it so that cannot be any good
it's even bad without a six but I
couldn't really refute it so let's let's
go for the next game oh my god Queen f2
yeah as I said it's a long day Wolverine
I haven't played him for a long time he
was a very frequent opponent in some
some month ago in the summer month yeah
we had a couple of he plays with these
three always and then shuffles and
shuffles and shuffles and shuffles and
tries to win on time but it works it
sometimes really works so what are you
doing yet d 4 or not and I don't think
there are non ICC streams plant this
week nope don't have the time I tried
last week and couldn't couldn't do it
they are never really a waste of time
it's just that there's the hot autumn
day way I don't want to play chess you
know it's sometimes it gets a bit much
you know yeah the main point against
this player is to not lose on time
because he will play quick moves and
will not stop doing that
so one idea for you i will it take that
night but i know i'm going to take I
guess and maybe like g6 prevent anything
coming to f5 that's a good position here
for black Bishop 1c2 doesn't a list of
the band words are their band words I
don't know okay I'm going over to have
six
come on yeah so um how to take I can
take with the rook ever want so just
just the endgame here yeah let's play
the endgame here for maybe slightly
better in their endgame
okay I Bishop c4 is better i played this
a little bit too relaxed it's I mean if
you if you really don't expect good
moves to happen it sometimes it's
difficult if they really happen and he
played it well usually it just shuffles
around without any any kind of a diamond
to be honest I'm just honest with you
usually just playing on time from move
one but this time you played well ok now
i'm ok again I think maybe root be six
maybe look b6 as a nation issue ok so
here you can take efore take is six no
band words aloud I have no idea what's
band here in the channel it's probably
something automatically happening move
the moobot don't know what that is so
let's see cannot do this how to play
here King f6 I guess hmm king of 6 kinjo
form
hmm ma it's not nothing terrible
happening here I think just have to be a
little bit precise
I'm trying for e3 and f6 check made okay
I can even give up the e4 pawn and sued
wrong but I think you have to nurse line
against the against the black Medina
gambit is good d4 Knight f6 93d 5e 4d
takes d4 f3c 6 what happened saman oh
I'm sorry he disconnected and for faiths
he disconnected I'm sorry I only
recognized him how the clock didn't tech
didn't take no I have no tournament in
view at the moment okay so one more game
against mr. Stefan docs from Belgium
strong I am a really good opponents only
title players really so he placed the
Kings Indian surprisingly I didn't think
that was part of his regular repertoire
so I got a Ben Oni I guess don't want to
take now he wants to take e takes is
considered to be slightly better for
white
there's a question can you explain why
the rule of pest we should be seven is
played first and then be five but not
the other way around and yeah I think I
can explain that if you start with B 5
and then Bishop e7 there are quick d 4
options it can be somewhat tricky yeah
yeah my opponent sacrifice the exchange
this exchange sacrifice is not entirely
correct objectively but in blitz chess
it's a very valid option as the dark
squares are so weak so it's something
that I wouldn't recommend to do an in
longer time controller chess but in
blitz why not so I'm trying to and fight
against them a night yarn on age 5 it
has been played by strong players I
think merasa which played at once so
let's see here the dark squares are
really really getting problematic so
what to do I'm happy to return the
exchange under some circumstances 22
maybe he will check them and then King
edge to like Queenie 5 hmm don't like
this position I'm going back here I
don't want to see the bishop coming
quickly
and what's the longest chess game you've
played I'm not quite sure i've i've
played in the dutch league i've played a
game with more than 100 moves once when
my opponent had to make me with the
night and bishop and he didn't know how
to do that but ultimately managed after
some adventures he stumbled into the
mate didn't really know what was going
on it was 120 moves or so and obviously
quite frustrating so I'm not quite sure
what to do here really hate this
position and blitz it's terrible to play
this kind of stuff Teague takes King
edge one or something it's not fun
take king h1 is all kinds of tactics
already 94 should be five well let's
offer to play in blitz awful now I have
no idea it just looks bad very simple to
play for black
yeah i know i'm coming from age two but
it's very difficult to find anything
great Jim Bishop age six maybe you can
also play how he takes takes a pawn not
exactly I don't really mind it that much
getting some stuff traded here at least
Wow I mean he sees better anyway
especially in a practical game I mean
and I mean in a blitz came not talking
about correspondence chess it's just
important to being able to play simple
move see you can just take F 364 and
he's fine yellow to checkmate 1995 goes
back there I cannot take due to Bishop
b5 and he wants to take and play Bishop
b5 I guess okay should be ready to I can
take h3 maybe I ok 95 m is probably
possible
what's the single most important advice
you could give to a sub 1500 player and
yeah be aware of what you do in the game
so be aware of you have unprotected
pieces unprotected pawns if you have
things that are not easy to handle pins
yeah or that something is kind of shaky
yeah those kind of things are important
to recognize in your opponent's
positions and in your position so be
aware of those those things and try to
avoid avoid tricky situations if the if
your opponent is in a tricky situation
try to recognize that and exploit that
quite often you can exploit those
dependencies and then problems let's get
out of the diagonal yeah multicast is an
engine i guess it was sometimes for some
time believed that might be magnus
carlsen or some other strong strong
human player but it's probably an engine
it was an engine so I'm going stepping
out of this here
yeah but I have to have to get rid of
that it's just I mean annoying is
putting it mildly that dark squared
bishop in this position and it's not
that I have compensation here but it's
still a playable position rookie won a
form i have some active ideas it's not
like lost i think see going for Bishop
g7 or okay take on c4 bishop age three i
also have queen to be seven just being
generally annoying attacking look at
bishop quincy cell okay
why is Wyoming women down on time I was
ahead on time I don't quite understand
what happened here why is the women down
on time that's weird very strange I
don't know what happened there now you
will win this simply on time
yeah i don't know i just played
exceptionally slowly at one point I was
ahead on the clock and then I got very
very slow so um guys this is the end of
the show yeah I hope you enjoyed enjoyed
them the show we had some very good good
games good opponents um especially
fabiano caruana I have got the world
number not quite sure what he is at the
moment I think it's number five or
something like that but he was the
number two even for a while training
magnus carlsen just buy a couple of
points yeah I hope you enjoyed it and
I'm i'll be back next week next Monday
thanks for watching